police raid a house in the town of
Gujarat in Pakistan's Punjab province
they're looking for a suspect they
believe could be responsible for
smuggling migrants into Europe
raids like this are being carried out
more than a week after an overloaded
fishing boat carrying migrants capsized
off the southern coast of Greece
Pakistan's economy in crisis and
inflation at almost 40 percent many are
risking their lives to find a better
future in Europe
more than 700 people are believed to
have died in one of the worst Refugee
tragedies in Europe
hundreds were from Pakistan
and there's anger amid the grief
this man lost his brother
we knew about the risks of trying to get
to Europe but what other options did we
have die here from hunger and poverty or
risk Our Lives to seek better
opportunities abroad
this mother says she paid more than
thirty thousand dollars to traffickers
to take her son
after the sad news of the boat capsizing
the government has asked for my DNA
sample so that my son can possibly be
identified
Mazar Iqbal tells investigators he
struck a deal with the man standing in
handcuffs next to him to get his son to
Europe
we are appealing to the government
please bring our sons back Dead or Alive
these cruel men took eleven thousand
dollars and we still lost our loved ones
he's ruined our lives
the man arrested in the raid admits
trafficking people
we had a deal eleven thousand dollars to
take their sons to Italy but we told
them about all the risks involved even
about the possibility of the boat
capsizing and them losing their sons but
they insisted I take them at any cost
the families of the victims share some
of their memories of those lost
and can only hope raids like these will
help prevent others suffering a similar
fate Michael Apple Al Jazeera